I'm librarian emila alcayat and this is
nnlm Discovery a podcast from the
network of the National Library of
Medicine this podcast explores how the
nnlm is engaging with communities to
provide access to trusted information
for the purpose of improving the
Public's health
in our first season of nnlm Discovery
all be your guide as we travel the
country exploring the engagement efforts
of the network of the National Library
of Medicine
we're going to visit a rural library in
Texas that brought telemedicine to their
town during the covid lockdown
so we are now in the Telehealth room it
used to be we called it a weeding room
donated books put in here when we
cleaned it out we found a smashed dead
frog under the book so we've come a long
way from then and we'll even travel to
Paradise to learn about how ham radio
can save lives after hurricanes strike
the Caribbean the islands were
devastated without the electricity
um internet cell phones cell phone
towers were out it was it was horrible
and yes this season we'll even talk to
real librarians
how many Librarians do you know who wear
cowboy boots and know how to hook up a
trailer hitch
in Wyoming all of us
Librarians are doing a lot more than
just checking out books throughout this
season you'll hear stories about Equity
Community Partnerships and the
extraordinary efforts of individuals
improving the health of their local
communities
please join us for season one of nnlm
Discovery subscribe wherever you get
your podcasts